[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
con este clarinete y con stravinsky se
puede llenar un perdido pueblo de españa
soy daniel bronca no lo voy a intentar
pues ilustrar os con unas cuantas ideas
y que salga de aquí siendo una gente
súper inteligentes efervescente super
ilustrada y sobre todo rebatir unas
cuantas inexactitudes siguiendo el tema
de hoy sobre la música clásica y sobre
el mundo rural
segura de la sierra en jaén es un pueblo
de 140 habitantes y muchos más gatos
en una en una comarca que no tiene
muchas posibilidades que no tiene mucho
empleo que pierde población
yo nací en el pueblo de bajo orcera
cuando tenía unos 8 años sufrió una
especie de ataque de músico phil ya
fortuitamente fui a escuchar una
orquesta sinfónica me quedé sin hablar
un par de días y el remedio parecía ser
tocar un instrumento yo mismo empecé con
el clarinete estudié en orcera en madrid
en parís en londres que es el completo
antónimo de segura de la sierra
y allí se me se me olvidó volver
todo comenzó volviendo a un sueño de
adolescencia en mi sueño de la
adolescencia era que algún alguna
superestrella de la música algún día le
diese por hacer un festival de música en
segura hasta que comprendí que tal vez
no hacía falta que fuese una
superestrella sino que un músico de
carne y hueso e incluso yo podría
hacerlo empecé a hablar con unos y con
otros sobre la idea de hacer un festival
con unos cuantos conciertos en mayo
es verdad que cundía el escepticismo de
tú con tu clarinete con stravinsky quien
va a venir aquí en mayo con la cantidad
de bodas y bautizos que hay
el festival empezó en 2014 con seis
conciertos hechos a base de un clavo y
de un martillo con muy pocos recursos y
creció hasta ser el hermoso festival que
es hoy en día música insegura un
festival de delicatessen musicales en el
cual reinterpretamos el paisaje
histórico industrial social natural de
la sierra de segura en jaén aglutinamos
a un público que en los últimos seis
años después de estos 100 conciertos
sobrepasa los 35 mil espectadores que
vienen de todos los rincones de españa y
que cala mucho en la comarca y que está
hecho a base de nuestra singular apuesta
por la excelencia musical por la
combinación de géneros musicales y por
esta asociación creativa entre tipos de
música y entornos hacemos por ejemplo
pues un concierto en una almazara de
aceite una instalación sonora en unos
baños árabes un desayuno musical con
concierto al amanecer muchos géneros que
hacen que el festival atraiga a gente
con la intención de crear una chispa en
el pueblo situarlo en el mapa generar
ingresos hacer que como hemos hecho que
incluso se vendan casas de gente que ha
conocido el pueblo a través del festival
y todo eso pues a partir de nuestros da
vince que nuestros mozas nuestra música
de jazz esta música que a priori no
movería tantísima gente
en la primera inexactitud que yo querría
rebatir es que la música clásica es algo
obsoleto y que no mueve gente
es verdad que a lo largo del tiempo la
música clásica ha sido embalsamados ha
ido en kilos 'no se ha ido perdiendo los
resquicios de los grandes auditorios y
tanatorios del país
pero es cierto que cuando se le quita el
formol cuando se le quita la profilaxis
tiene un poder indiscutible que puedes
disfrutar hoy a rosalía y mañana a
monteverdi y eso es lo que lo que creo
yo personalmente lo que creemos en el
festival y eso tiene mucho mucho tirón
esto me ha hecho ver que cuando se
innova
había mucho campo por hacer y que si se
puede innovar en la música clásica que
lleva así los siglos donde no se podrá
innovar
la segunda inexactitud que me gustaría
rebatir es que los pueblos se deban
dedicar a las procesiones ya las
chuletas
es verdad que a veces en el mundo urbano
tenemos esa imagen fija de los pueblos
como núcleos de población pequeños claro
pero que además son atrasados que son
tradicionales que son sosegados y cuando
se proponen modelos no de desarrollo
pues son solo un paso como la
agricultura ecológica si que sea
ecológica pero que se sigan dedicando de
agricultura
y que no rompen de verdad el esquema
creo que no necesariamente los pueblos
tienen que llevar que tiene que acarrear
esa secuencia de condiciones
socioeconómicas y en cuanto a eso la
cultura las industrias creativas las
artes escénicas tienen mucho que decir
para empezar porque las artes escénicas
se encuentran en el escenario perfecto
en los pueblos por ese entorno de
proximidad que suponen naturalmente y un
paso mucho más grande porque las
industrias creativas pueden ayudar a
otros sectores a otras organizaciones a
otras instituciones a pensar más allá de
lo literal a pensar más allá del olivar
de regadío a pensar más allá del paro
agrícola a dar un poco de vueltas la
cabeza en que otros modelos podrían
existir que no existen todavía porque yo
creo que el futuro de los pueblos de
españa pasa más por la creatividad que
por la tradición que hace falta
plantearse mucho de los clichés y dos
tópicos para empezar
quién son los del pueblo qué es lo de
dentro y los de fuera cada vez vemos más
modelos complejos con gente que vive
parte de su tiempo en los pueblos que va
que viene que telecom muta que trabaja
desde allí en otro sitio y eso es un
creo un buen comienzo para el futuro
porque no es tanto ser o estar de un
pueblo sino conectar con los pueblos y
si pensamos en estas conexiones si
pensamos en el gran bazar digital que se
está convirtiendo el mundo esa conexión
ya llegan a los pueblos lo que pasa que
de una forma bastante unidireccional
pensando en el festival de este año
hemos utilizado 18 grandes plataformas
digitales para las operaciones del
festival 15 norteamericanas una alemana
un estadounidense porque si lo pensáis
en el día a día se genera una lluvia
fina de dinero en estas nuevas
metrópolis digitales que a veces están
muy lejos de nuestra de donde nosotros
disfrutamos de esas nuevas habas que se
cuecen en otro sitio pero tendría que
ser así porque son ideas geniales que se
ejecutan con elmer y que se podrían
hacer por ejemplo en un pueblo
imaginaros que la gente de mi pueblo
estuviese generando dinero cada vez que
alguien en california o que alguien en
eeuu compre una entrada para un
concierto la naturaleza o que el hotel
en general se dinero cada vez que se
remodela unidad catedral gótica en
cualquier sitio del mundo y creo que hay
muchas oportunidades en el nuevo bazar
digital en el que se está convirtiendo
el mundo
creo que desde los márgenes y considero
que los rurales una periferia es un
margen también la música clásica hay
mucho espacio para innovar
no para dejarse llevar por lo que se
supone que no tiene que marcar la
tradición
que si se puede llenar un pueblo con
stravinsky con un clarinete quedan
muchas cosas que todavía están en el
desván y que hay que darles una
oportunidad creer en ellas y apostar por
ellas porque posiblemente la abuela del
visillo haya aprobado ya la ley de
protección de datos
muchas gracias y buenas noches
[Aplausos]